[Music]
two ccsd campuses could be getting a
huge chunk of change to upgrade security
but the discrepancy in the amounts for
each school is raising some additional
questions that's right victoria saha was
on this story today she breaks down what
funding will be used for and of course
reaction from teachers at other
locations who say they want their safety
considered as well
this past school year there were many
violent incidents reported ranging from
student fights that would put schools on
lockdown in april a student allegedly
attacked and sexually assaulted a
teacher at el dorado high school el
dorado now could be getting more than 26
million dollars in security upgrades i
understand the importance of making sure
that the staff and students at el dorado
feel safe after the horrible incident
that happened last year vicki criedel an
elementary school teacher and president
of a local teachers union doesn't
understand why clark high school is
getting almost a hundred thousand
dollars that's a huge difference from
the millions for el dorado documents
released by the school district show
both schools will get more security
cameras a secure single entry point to
the front of the school and on-site
fencing but what about the hundreds of
other schools within ccsd especially
considering what just happened in uvalde
end of the school year you know that was
in elementary school we should be
concerned
about every school when asked about the
discrepancy the school district said in
a statement in part each school
community has unique needs based on
current infrastructure to provide
security enhancements aging
infrastructure must also be repaired or
replaced in order to support the
security technology the cost will vary
from school to school victoria saha live
local now
we did reach out to the school district
for an itemized list of the upgrades and
expenses at this time they are keeping
them confidential
well we also reached out to both
principals from each school and only
heard back from clark county high school
now the principal there says she was not
ready to comment